I would just kind of look at it like as
an independent and get into the details
and be like this is exciting but it's
not that exciting and seems like really
really long way from being translational
to me because like it's so hard to
achieve this outcome a b there are all
these like potential negative side
effects from tumor genicity and these
sorts of things
um like we don't want to achieve full
partial reprogramming uh in Vivo we want
to do that or full reprogramming when it
we want to do it partially and so how do
we do that precisely
um and like then how do we figure out
like cell agnostic delivery like all
these different challenges and so I say
that to say that like it seemed really
really far off for me just thinking
about it like
empirically and so as I would look at
the same types of papers that we're
talking about now with like these types
of results like and I'd read into the
weeds of the methods and like how often
they would get these things to happen I
was like a lot more excited because it
seemed much more effective in regards to
like getting the desired outcome that we
want
um to actually happen if that makes
sense so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in today's video I
got the chance to catch up with a friend
of mine Benjamin Anderson who like many
of you listening considers himself a
lifelong learner having previously built
ones an Uber like platform for booking
housekeepers or more recently being an
executive producer for the France crate
broadcast Ben has been undertaking his
own independent Research into aging and
bioelectric networks
here we discuss why he thinks this may
be a good intervention point for
longevity and discuss some other topics
around his recent review article I hope
you enjoy
so hi Ben thank you for joining me today
and welcome to the cheeky Science Show
thank you for having me I'm really
excited to be here well I brought you
one because you recently wrote this
really interesting review article about
bioelectricity and of course you've
heard you talk about it before and so I
guess that seems is kind of curious
about your own personal backgrounds and
what led you to go into this research
area
um yeah so the the article specifically
came about it's kind of funny like I had
been researching the direction in the
sense of basically just like reading all
the papers that were out there and I
guess if I was to go a step back I would
say
um I produced a podcast with someone for
um about three years oh um and so about
a year and a half ago kind of came
across Michael Levin's work because he'd
hired a neuroscientist that we had on
before and so I was like who's this you
know guy doing developmental biology
information processing stuff who hired a
neuroscientist this is interesting and
so whenever he came on to talk about
some of these subjects and you've had
him on as well right and so found those
to be really interesting and started
just consuming as much as I could not
only just his work and some of the basic
functions that were sort of like what do
these mechanisms look like and how they
do they drive other aging related
mechanisms having like an interest in
the space and going back to like the
review paper specifically what I is
basically doing there to keep track of
these Concepts right because I'm like
you know copy pasting like the ideas
into this long running document and I
had it basically up as like a pre-print
on my own website so that like as I was
communicating with people in our space
as I'd go to conferences and whatnot I'd
be like well hey there's this Direction
that's being explored over in this place
of regenerative medicine that I think
more people in longevity biology should
be paying attention to and so like my
running argument for this was basically
like this document on my website with 30
40 50 of these papers I'd read and a
bunch of like copy pasted text blocks of
like the different aging related
mechanisms where there was like
insinuations of these things being
related and so that being said I sent it
to someone at one point and they were
like why have you not just done this
into a review paper right and for more
context on my background right like I'm
not in the institution right now or I'm
not even with a company I'm just kind of
doing independent research from the
Midwest and so I was like ah okay cool
that seems like a thing to do and so did
that and published it so did you have
much of a background in biology or was
this all completely novel
um topics for you to uncover
I um studied biology as an undergrad
here in St Louis for a little bit and
then I whenever I was in school I was
also running a software company and so
without getting into the weeds of the
software company I basically dropped out
to focus on that for a few years
um and then eventually sold it sometime
through covid and that sort of put me in
the position to start doing the things
like working on this podcast with my
partner Vance and that gave me the time
to start sort of researching these
things that I had always been interested
in but I personally felt like it was too
late to go back to school and that's
surely never the case right but that was
just the decision that I made and so I
started sort of paying attention to
these things independently well I have
to recommend to my audience you'll work
your article because I think it does
give a really good overview of the the
current states of the fields and also I
think it's written at a really good
level that should in theory be
accessible to most people even if they
don't necessarily have such a strong
biology backgrounds so kudos to you
firstly but also I just I think we
should probably now actually address
what exactly is bioelectricity and maybe
you could give some sort of overview to
the field
yeah so bioelectricity is
um like sort of encapsulates in my mind
I think the concept that's important to
understand is like sort of
um two different gradients that are
interacting at like the level of the
cell and so when I say like interact
ingredients I say that like there's sort
of the
um the chemical gradient and then
there's the the bioelectric gradient
right and it's this idea that like the
chemical concentrations of the level of
like the cell
um because those carry charges create
the um electrical gradient and so
bioelectricity to me sort of
encapsulates like
um those two things and how they
interact and like the changes
um over time and how that type of
signaling sort of between cells can
actually be causally Upstream of
different
transcriptional outcomes at the level of
individual cell of the individual cell
and that's what I think is most sort of
interesting about this work and so
coming in from like a software
engineering background right like it
just made intuitive sense like I
remember listening to some of the early
talks on the space and like the analogy
would be given but like think about it
like the software rather than the
biological Hardware right and so if you
think about that right there's like two
ways that you can bring about change and
like you know say like a computer you
could you know Eleanor could pull off
the back and she could take a soldering
iron to her apple to try to change how
it works in that sort of way and um like
for all intents and purposes that's a
lot of what we're doing in biology we're
kind of taking the soldering iron to the
circuit board and so I see
bioelectricity as sort of this idea of
like ah there actually is this more
abstracted layer in which information is
being processed and biological systems
and if we can find ways to alter what's
going on there then we might be able to
more effectively bring about the
outcomes that we're looking to achieve
in a variety of different modalities not
just aging it's also it got me most
excited about it in general and so
obviously I think a lot of you people
understand the concepts of that being
information in written in the genetic
codes but what ways in
um are there which information
potentially could be stored in this
bioelectric codes
um the ways that the information is
stored uh is in it to me at least I
would say patterns of change over time
um and so if we think about it in terms
of like it's we can we can simplify it
in terms of like there's
multiple different types of ions that
are being moved around to carry signals
between cells and so when a certain
concentration of a given ion builds up
there's a lot of different things that
might happen Downstream of like that
sort of chemical State being the case
um and so the way that like I was saying
before the chemical State sort of
tethers this to the electrical gradient
is because we have things like
voltage-gated ion channels that will
open whenever a given like membrane
potential is reached across the cell
membrane and then it'll allow sort of
like a flux of those ions to move
like and diffuse across an area to carry
a signal and so as that signal gets
carried and those
metabolites or ions The small molecules
move to different regions of like
whether it's a group of cells or a whole
organism that can lead to other like
transcriptional outcomes is there's
activate different signaling Pathways
and so that's sort of the way that I
would think about it in terms of like
holding information and carrying signals
and so you mentioned that you read
obviously a lot of different papers to
write this review article and you had
this like collection of them on your
blog sides what one today is like were
most interesting to your most compelling
um and would you like to discuss them in
more detail
yeah the the the one that there were a
couple that really hooked me I guess the
one that I would mention first is there
was like sort of a systematic study
um of like genome-wide transcriptional
changes
um that were like they were basically
doing a systematic study of what happens
at the level of
um like the cell in the transcriptional
state during depolarization and so what
they found is that um there were
actually a number of different
um cell fate uh genes that were
activated like their expression levels
would change Downstream of
um the membrane potential of the cells
changing so I was like well this is
really interesting like we're seeing
that yeah these like cell cell
differentiation genes are being
activated by the bioelectric state so
there was this that I found that was
really interesting
um another one was going back as early
as the 60s there was someone I can't
remember if he came to this Insight but
there was a guy named Clarence Cohn that
induced a mitotic block just by changing
the intraocellular ionic concentration
to I think to depolarize replicating
cells and so the reason that he did this
study in the 60s was because again I I
don't have that like right in my head
but in any case like around the time
like it was found that membrane
potential values vary throughout the
cell cycle and so what this study was
basically doing was seeing can we
decouple or can we find out whether
that's like uh just like not randomly
collinear or which one is causal to the
other right and so that's why he did
this sort of like well let's do the
simple thing here and just change the
ionic concentration to change the
membrane potential of these dividing
cells and what he found was yeah we can
actually block mitosis from happening
whenever we do this and not only can we
block it right but it's reversible So
then whenever uh like the extracellular
environment sort of returned like sort
of a normal ionic concentration mitosis
would continue
um and so those were two of the more and
then obviously like I could talk all day
about like Michael Levin's research
right but I would definitely Point
people to your interview with him where
he talks about some of the things that
his lab has done one of my favorite
examples is
um sort of like as simple as I just
described right with the two-headed
planaria where a play area is a very
simple worm species right where like
it's highly replicated or highly
replicative or regenerative it never
gets cancer these sorts of things and so
an interesting model organism in the
context of Aging but he found that
whenever they would sort of cut them
they wanted to find out like you know
there's this blastema around the cut
site and it regenerates and so what
happens whenever that worm is trying to
regenerate whenever the again the ionic
concentrations in the environment
surrounding that blast stem are
different and so they found that
whenever they
um depolarized that environment with
Ivermectin that some percentage of the
time they would get a two-headed
phenotype they were like this is really
interesting why is this the case right
and so
um yeah things things like this like
caught my attention especially because
like again having like my Bend of focus
on Aging in the longevity space I was
similarly like enamored by papers coming
out on like the latest progress on
uncovering mechanisms of cellular
reprogramming and to be totally honest
the more I would get into the weeds of
these things like without the bias of
excitement of like being part of one of
these projects or a lab or anything is
like I would just kind of look at it
like as an independent and get into the
details and be like this is exciting but
it's not that exciting and seems like
really really long way from being trans
isolational to me because like it's so
hard to achieve this outcome a b there
are all these like potential negative
side effects from tumor genicity and
these sorts of things
um like we don't want to achieve full
partial reprogramming in Vivo we want to
do that or full reprogramming when we
want to do it partially and so how do we
do that precisely
um and like then how do we figure out
like cell agnostic delivery like all
these different challenges and so I say
that to say that like it seemed really
really far off for me just thinking
about it like
empirically and so as I would look at
the same types of papers that we're
talking about now with like these types
of results like and I'd read into the
weeds of the methods and like how often
they would get these things to happen I
was like a lot more excited because it
seemed much more effective in regards to
like getting the desired outcome that we
want
um to actually happen if that makes
sense yeah yeah you made many
interesting points there firstly I have
to agree with you that I also think the
two-headed planarians is possibly my
favorite uh study I think that's super
fascinating but also you mentioned the
work I've done by Karen we've been
looking at how the the voltage potential
across the the membrane changes during
the cell cycle which actually was also
somewhat novel information to myself
because I understood that all cells have
this sort of like resting membrane
potential and I think I think most
classical biologists learn it in the
context of neurons and how they have
these Action potentials to transmit
information in the brain but also cells
in the pancreas also use it to regulate
States I think insulin secretion say
regulating glucose levels and also the
other cell type that I learn about is
like the heart cells and how they have
the contract uh how it regulates their
contractility I didn't no no if that's a
word but I'm going to use it
um and so obviously I was curious
because these are the three cell types
like say neurons pancreas hearts that
have this sort of like known
fluctuations a lot within uh their
membrane potential and also I guess now
cells that are replicating a lot also
probably have a lot of changes during
the cell cycle as you you mentioned and
so is there some sort of interesting
connection between cells that already
have a lot of Dynamics in their membrane
potential and potentially some sort of
ability to reprogram those cells
um ability to reprogram already
excitable cells they're saying like
cardiac cells and neurons and these
sorts of exactly yeah I mean
um
that's one of the things that I think
about most whenever I'm because like I
could go into the Weeds on what I or
where I think there might be potential
intervention strategies that are aging
related or whatever related to This
research but in any case I think that's
one of the biggest challenges to be
overcome in this space is like how do
you do
um a uh intervention that alters the
resting membrane potential which the
resting membrane potential is just
basically the mid-range and this like
range of variability of change right
there's this wave pattern that we're
talking about of the cell depolarizes
and then it polarizes and then
depolarizes and polarizes based off of
the
concentrations of these ions moving
carrying that electrochemical gradient
right that just happens to your point a
lot faster in excitable cells and so if
we were to look at like some type of
intervention that um uh you know Alters
this pattern of change that's carrying
like these signals across like a given
you know region of cells to get things
to happen transcriptionally we like I
don't know actually if it would be
easier or harder in existing excitable
cells but uh yeah like how would you not
interrupt these patterns that do do
things like maintain like cardiac
homeostasis or brain function these
sorts of things so it's like a good
question I don't know if it would
actually be like easier or harder
because they're already excitable at
like a faster timeline yeah I see and I
also like the point you mentioned before
how
um the interfering at this high level
um seems so simple like with the
experiments you mentioned it's just a
simple block of maybe one receptor
protein or just adding a chemical that
loses the charge and it seems like a
much simpler approach than to add you
know subsets of genes and get them
integrated into the cell or get them
expressed in the cell so why yeah what
other advantages are there to
understanding this bioelectric level as
opposed to trying to intervene lower
down
um to me the biggest opportunity is
effectiveness of outcome uh and so the
reason I say that is going back to this
idea of like cellular reprogramming
right like in most cases we can only get
that to happen like one two percent of
the time and like a culture of cells but
then you look at some interesting
studies in regards to like having this
small molecule in the environment is
able to increase the effectiveness of
cellular reprogramming right and so
um that being said as far as like
thinking about exciting things to be
able to do
um with this type of research I guess
one thing that I would talk about is if
you think about
um like a group of cells as like a like
a group of cells is like a collective
that can like learn
um there was another interesting like
study that came out of Levin's lab that
basically asked the question of can we
get cells to learn like in this
pavlovian style model and so if you're
familiar with like the the you know can
we get the dog to salinate after enough
time if we just ring a bell and like
take the treat away because we've
trained it to associate these two things
and so one of the questions that they
asked is can we train a gene regulatory
Network in the same sort of way and
we're getting kind of out of like
bioelectricity specifically but I think
that bioelectricity and this idea of
like infra information processing and
biological substrates is like really
really
kind of one in the same more or less
it's more of just like bioelectricity is
like the control mechanism for how that
information is processed to guide a
given like mechanical outcome at the
level of the cell and so whenever they
did this study to just wrap that point
like they found that they could they
could do a
um like the use case was say take like a
harmful intervention that like maybe has
some outcome that we want that outweighs
its cost whether it's like a depression
drug or a cancer therapeutic or
something like this but it has all these
other side effects that like we don't
want
um but the fact that you know we're
wanting to get to this one goal State
makes it worth taking anyways they ask
the question can we like do a harmful
intervention like that in tandem with
um the benign the secondary stimulus
over enough time to train the network to
activate the pathway that we want only
with the benign stimulus and um like
they had predominantly done like
computational modeling there but they
suggest that that's the case and now
there's like some exciting stuff
happening sort of in that direction so
that would be another thing in regards
to thinking about these types of
mechanisms we're talking about that's
just like there's so many applications
and you know like oncology is another
one there's a lot of interesting stuff
regarding like cancer detection by not
looking at mutations at the level of the
individual cell but um alterations to
membrane potential in these types of
sites and so in terms of thinking about
the things that we know and the things
that we don't know like something that
we do know is that proliferative
proliferative cells have a more
depolarized phenotype right and so we if
we look at like sort of the spectrum of
um like the resting membrane potential
of multiple different types of cells or
different tissues or whatnot like
somatic differentiated cells that like
have very stable States like don't
replicate very often are very very
polarized and then like say cancer cells
the liver cells sort of in the mid-range
it's like 40 millivolts is like it's
resting membrane potential but like
cancer cells we see like a marked
decrease
in the resting membrane potential in
cancer cells right and like the region
sort of surrounding them and so what is
the way to think about that as it
pertains to this idea of like
information processing well it's like if
I'm very depolarized and you're very
depolarized we're in like a much more
we're much closer to equilibrium there's
not like a
um you know like the the voltage is like
how badly does it charge when it move
from one side of a barrier to another
and if we think of that as like an
information signal and like there's more
depolarization that means that basically
like the rate at which the charge is
moving across the barriers is
um uh lower so it's like less in
cohesive communication with the region
around it if that sort of no it does
kind of
sensitive
less sensitive to changes or
or less less less coupled to its its
environment so like all cells are
individual entities that are like
communicating signals to orient towards
a goal State and so if we see a cell
that should usually be like say within
this given range of
um uh like it's it's membrane potential
and that dips below
um and we see that that's cohesive with
cancer well like what's interesting
about cancer right this idea that like
um it's a cell that seems to be
regressing to like an individual state
of function of like oh I don't care
about maintaining cohesiveness with the
environment that I'm embedded in I just
want to replicate rapidly and get as
much Resource as I can to drive my sort
of individual goal State and not like
the environment school state that I'm
coupled to interesting see um I do
probably know the answer to this but I
did
um so your constant cells tend to be
depolarized but obviously my area of
Interest are senescent cells which in
many ways are not proliferative they
have this aerofascial cell cycle arrest
and so do you know if anyone's looked
into
um the barrier like the resting membrane
potential of senescent cells and if
there's any potential interest in maybe
looking into this
I don't at least not to my knowledge
that I'd be able to like say like quote
or talk to I'm super fascinated by this
because like my hypothesis would be is
that it's like sort of the other end of
the spectrum
um but like I don't have any concrete
like say data to back that up and that
goes back to this idea of like
um a lot of the potential overlaps with
like things you can do with like this
research is speculative right now
because it's like so new
um and I think one of the things that's
needed is more systematic studies like
the one that I was sort of mentioning
saying like
um let's look at not just the
transcriptional state of multiple
different types of cells or tissue types
in different disease states to get like
sort of like our gene expression Omnibus
right like we need to do that in tandem
with looking at
um these sort of like electrochemical
behaviors of cells so that we can have
more information then that's me like
speaking as a computationalist like
that's the thing that like I'm
consistently exploring directions that I
find interesting and because it's so new
I'm like dissuaded by the or not
dissuaded I'm just like ah we've like
run out of like I that's why like this
big paper that like it's been looking at
a bunch of little mechanisms that like
provide hints at something that might be
possible and there's like very very few
of these comprehensive studies that have
said like okay we've perturbed like you
know
um this system and all these different
ways to create this sort of like
comprehensive overview of
um like how this might be related or the
the bioelectric state might be related
to Downstream transcriptional outcomes
in the cell
um and to answer your question I guess
again to uh senescence like there might
be a study out there I just I don't I
don't there's not a ton of this work
that's been like directly tied to aging
yet
um you had someone else I think that's
doing some of the more exciting work in
the space that's not like that the level
of the whole cell but whenever you
interviewed Brandon Barry
um with like mitochondrial membrane
potential Rejuvenation right it's like
that makes total sense because reduced
mitochondrial membrane potential impairs
the uptake of calcium in the cell and so
if like the uptake of calcium is
dysregulated then because of like
mitochondrial membrane potential
decreasing then that could decrease like
the ability of like calcium homeostasis
at the level of the whole cell and
signaling of this like
um sort of like that that
mitochondrial dysfunction propagating up
that seems to be like a really good
um uh Pathway to be like sort of
exploring and so that's other research
that's sort of like around these
mechanisms that has me excited no sure
yeah actually that that was a very
interesting paper
um by Brandon um and so going back to
more your interests in the
bioelectricity uh Fields I think I heard
you mentioned in another talk that you
use a tool called Betsy and I guess I'm
just somewhat curious about what exactly
are the questions that you're interested
in answering in this space
um what sort of information do you need
to do it
the um so Betsy just a um like Point
people towards it like it's a
computational tool that was created
Again by Levin's lab stands for
bioelectric tissue simulation engine
um and so my main research question is
um like the main thing that my main
research question is
can we achieve something like cellular D
differentiation
without any intervention that involves
transcript like the transcription
factors like the yamanaka factors
um that's the thing that I'm curious
about and in terms of like again me not
being someone who like currently Works
inside of like a lab or
these sorts of things like I've been
looking for this type of data in regards
to like things like protein expression
levels for ION channels and GAP
Junctions during cellular reprogramming
or like at least if I can't find it for
during like cellular reprogramming
specifically what does it look like
during different stages of
differentiation during like guided stem
cell differentiation that's not directly
like with an aging overlap the other
thing that's important to understand is
like what there's another really useful
tool that they built called Eden and
when I say they I mean again like 11 lab
is doing a lot of This research so I
keep pointing to them because they're
creating a lot of like the early stage
resources for helping people explore
this space
um and so they have this tool for
looking for
pre-existing FDA like approved drugs
that modulate
um like ION channel activity in some
sort of way and so looking in these
types of databases to say like let's go
Upstream of trying to
um just
up regulate the expression of yamanaka
factors in the cell can we look for
um ION channel drugs specifically that
increase the expression of these factors
and so like there's a series of those
that I found and so like the things that
I spend my time doing like with this
specifically is
um modeling that to see if I can get
um like it's temporal data to see if I
can get like an initial State basically
to move towards a reprogrammed state but
that's where
um I'm like okay I'm a computationalist
and I'm basically playing with like the
limits of like what I know and
understand
um and uh yeah I think the next steps
are more people need to be like taking
some of these interventions to be like
okay like it seems like there's a
promising indication here now let's like
take this to the lab and see if we can
get something like this to happen yeah
because you've mentioned now 11's lab a
couple of times and I'm just curious I
mean how many labs are doing this sort
of research at the moment or
specifically I guess yeah
there's there's there's one that I pay a
lot of attention to here like in St
Louis as well
um Samantha Morris's lab at Washington
University
um she's really focused on
um more effective cellular reprogramming
and guided stem cell differentiation and
these sorts of things so it's really
like orthogonal research
um but it doesn't have like directly
um a uh like regenerative medicine Focus
or an aging Focus or anything like this
it's it's really just like mechanisms of
stem cell differentiation and these
sorts of things so that's another lab
that I pay attention to
um uh there's another that's coming my
mind but yeah I guess like they're
they're not very many people out there
that are looking at like the
transcriptional state in tandem with the
bioelectric state is I guess what I
would say like you've got like say a lab
like Levins that's doing a lot of like
the great work coupling those two levels
of information processing together which
is what I think we need more of um but
then other than that like their Labs you
know doing physiology related work I
guess like I pay less attention to
individual labs and I do a lot of like
work where I'm just like coming across
interesting papers and aggregating
information and mechanisms and these
sorts of things to like sort of build my
conceptual model but I've like been
hitting and we've talked about this a
little bit like I'm hitting this point
where like I'm limited in the degree of
being able to do so to enough degree
that's like actually needing to be in a
lab doing this work because it's just
kind of you can only aggregate disparate
information from uh like an independent
position for so long before you need to
get your hands dirty and build in the
space of atoms rather than the space of
bits well leading on from that I think
it's firstly very impressive that you
have done this little independently and
you've made it look like super easy but
was it as trivial to be able to get all
this information or to to actually do
this independent research and sort of
what are the challenges that you sort of
face with it
um I would I mean hey I would say I'm
humbled to be here right like I've been
watching The Cheeky side show for years
and so like uh you know watching things
like this to get information about
exciting things that are happening in
the space
um you know it was really beneficial to
have something like the podcast as well
like I didn't host the conversations
like you but as I got involved with this
project with my partner who does host it
um he kind of gave me the opportunity to
reach out to people that were doing work
that I thought was interesting
um and that was an opportunity to build
relationships with people in this space
and maintain conversations with them and
these sorts of things reading lots of
papers other people that I would say
that just like in terms of like how I've
thought of getting involved in this
space coming from like a non-traditional
background I mean that would very much
be the challenge like I remember the
first real academic conference I went to
was the GRC systems aging conference uh
like a year or two ago in May and so in
any case like things like that
um you know I had to get myself to I
wasn't like part of an academic lab that
would like pay for Ben to go do this
thing and talk to people but I would be
like doing work and exploring an area
that made me curious and reading papers
but again like sort of being landlocked
it's like you don't know what you don't
know sort of thing and so something that
I guess is my biggest challenge that I
continue to try to do is put myself in
situations where I like have to go
communicate ideas and have them be
judged against others in the space to
sort of validate how much that like I
actually know because even like as I'm
exploring things like I talk to people
as much as I can
um to sort of iron out ideas and I put
myself in settings like this to talk
with other people that are doing this
work
but I would say that's probably the
biggest challenge is that when you're
working as an independent and you don't
have like a lab or an environment that
you're embedded in 100 of the time like
you it becomes really easy and I think a
lot of people who are in Labs or you
know guiding research do this anyways
but it gets really easy to become like
you know say like the term of like
drinking your own Kool-Aid right of like
kind of getting landlocked in your own
direction of exploration and not being
super receptive to counter ideas and I
think that to counter your question of
the challenges that's like one of the
advantages to kind of being independent
because like I'm not in a lab where I'm
like 100 focused on validating their
research right
um or exploring like a facet of it
that's been delegated to me I'm like the
only thing Ben cares about is like
understanding the mechanisms of aging
and like searching for the most
effective interventions in this space
and so as I like independently combed
the landscape of like a lot of what
people
um were doing I was like this research
being done at Tufts seems to be the most
of most important work being done in
biology that hasn't yet effectively
disseminated into how people are
thinking about like aging related
Rejuvenation right and so
um I think that that is sort of yeah to
counter like the challenge question I'd
say like that's one of the good things
of working independent is like so long
as like you don't let yourself get track
trapped in your own dogma and I try to
be really really cognizant of that and
so I
um yeah I'm always very open to to
challenge whenever I'm talking through
things but I continue to feel more and
more rooted in the things that I am
exploring because of
going to places like where you met right
but of course yeah I mean I think it's
really important because it's so easy to
fall into that Chapel just being
convinced of your idea and not wanting
to change you have to be open to new
ideas and new information
um and be able to uh adjust accordingly
and so you mentioned um just a bit
before that with your own independent
research now you're getting to the point
that maybe you're needing more
information to go to the next stage and
so you did briefly mention Offline that
you're sort of exploring New
Opportunities maybe to try and collect
some of this information would you like
to explore on more detail to the
audience
yeah for sure I am like uh I've actually
started buying lab equipment for myself
to like do some of these things now and
like there there are people out there
that are doing this like I you know
um have visited people who have sort of
like independent Labs or met people at
conferences that like
um I'm I'm not 100 unique in this idea
of like doing independent research the
other people who've sort of like got
like become dissuaded by being like
embedded in the wrong academic setting
or maybe not necessarily feeling like
they're far enough along to like dive
down like the industry route yet and so
they just want to continue doing like
the basic research um independently
without being like you know constrained
in any other way and so like if you have
sort of like the time and means to do so
to like get in a lab there's there are
the thing I would say that makes me in
this position of like now acquiring
equipment is like there are
opportunities out there to like work in
co-working Labs right
um there's like some good spaces
especially in the bay in Boston where
you have like these sort of biotech
co-working spaces where there's like
some basic equipment and you can pay
your monthly fee and get access to those
spaces
and I kind of sort of looked at my
options here in St Louis because frankly
I'm not looking to move to one of the
coasts for a number of reasons but in
any case like
um yeah long story short started like
buying equipment because it was like if
I'm going to pay this to be embedded in
this space why don't I just start
getting some of these things and I am
thankfully in the position now where I
like am communicating somewhat regularly
with people that are actually doing
experimental research and who've been
like very generous to sort of like give
me some of their time to talk through uh
like how I'll have to be thinking about
doing these sorts of things because you
know you do the funny thing where you
like start researching online what are
the things I need to do a given like
assay and like okay let me talk to
someone to make sure I designed that
assay right to begin with and then it's
like okay I've got like you know say 50
to 75 000 worth of equipment here but
then like I talked to a bunch of other
people that have done some of these into
dependent lab type setups and it's like
you know lab equipment is like worse
than cars in terms of like depreciating
the second it leaves the lot so to speak
and so they're like actually if you
think about this differently you can get
all this equipment you need for like you
know a fraction of the cost and so that
got me excited enough and I feel
convicted enough in some of the
directions that I'm exploring
um that I've literally just within the
last few weeks started buying some of
this equipment as I like narrow in what
I need to do the things that I'm
exploring
um and I'll hopefully be having some
friends like me coming out to visit and
play with these things and they have
their own directions that they're
exploring and we'll work on things
together and try to build this different
this different secret third thing this
like new Option of like uh maybe just
seeing how far you can go doing the
independent research thing I mean I'm
super curious myself into this
independent research approach because
it's easier maybe to sit in the states
than other countries and like you
mentioned how you want to stay in St
Louis and not potentially go to Boston
or the West Coast like what yeah what
are the the main challenges I guess
besides course
um
the main challenges besides costs I
would say are
[Music]
um
I think I mean cost like to be totally
honest I think cost is one of the
biggest barriers I'm trying to think of
something else where it's like like I
said like I I have connections in the
space I talk to people I'm like if I
wanted to do something to do this how
should I be thinking about doing this
like okay I've designed this assay is
this like right like please give me
feedback I need to make this better it's
like well this is the way you want to
think about this it's like okay like I
need someone to do this with how should
I do this okay how do I use like you
just keep asking the next question and
then it gets to the point of like okay
where do I do the work because now I
figure out I figured out everything I
think I need to figure out and that's
where I'm like the thing that deterred
me was like the options were go put
myself in an academic lab somewhere
um and like I could do that
um I guess but like I don't want to for
like a number of other reasons um like
like
um but and then there's like the cost
function of like you have spaces like
this where it's like say in St Louis
there's like co-working lab space
available but it's like two thousand
dollars a month for like really really
basic equipment you know and I mean and
it doesn't have everything I need I need
to buy these things anyways and so I
guess I'm rambling around your question
but in any case like I can't think of a
big deterrent other than cost other than
maybe perception I guess to be totally
Frank
um and like uh credibility like that's
been
um
like I've never felt really really like
embraced with that but like there's a
hundred percent that like you know if
you're exploring a direction or if
you're like doing research and you don't
have like the four to eight years of
study like and there's a lot of reasons
for why you should like there's like
it's like proof of work there right that
you've like understood things deeply
enough to you know
um be able to do these sorts of things
so I think that's probably one of the
other main challenges is just but if
it's like if you have your time and you
have your resources and like you have
peers to sort of like vet your ideas
with
then it's like you know just go go I
guess yeah and I think you're right I
mean I think yeah ultimately most things
can probably be traced back to cost
being some sort of barrier
um and so let's say of course up take
out take cost out of the equation and
let's say now that you're able to gather
this information that you're looking for
what kind of would be like the endpoints
or the ends goal with getting this
information into the membrane potential
and linking that with reprogramming as
in what do you hope to do with this
information
um in the long term
um well so there's like the there's the
the answer to the question in terms of
like what medium to be working in and
how specifically to be applying the
research I just want to make sure you're
asking the like uh the latter like how
to do it with from the research
perspective
I guess if I was to be totally Frank
that's a large reason why like people
are like Ben why haven't you done just
the company thing yet and like I still
feel like I'm at the basic research
stage right and so that's where I'm like
I have
a Direction that's really exciting and
there's a lot of these mechanisms that
we've talked about and I've done some
computational stuff to give me like to
be like okay it seems like there's
something here and like maybe that's
enough
um but uh in in any case like
um in terms of like how something like
that might become translatable anything
I say from this point on I guess I'd say
that to say would be speculation but um
something that interests me a lot in
regards to This research is this idea
that there's like this range of
variability and there's the static value
which is the steady state membrane
potential right and so
um what we can see also is that like
over time the steady state membrane
potential decreases
um and so the thing that makes me
curious is like what are the types of
interventions that we might be able to
do to
um
reset that value so to speak to or to
like to re-widen that range of
variability and like where that goes
back to is like the rate of
um energy production in the cell itself
and so to go back to Cellular
reprogramming one of the more
interesting things that I don't hear a
lot about like in the Aging space but
like was I was diving into it is there's
this thing that like it's the Warburg
effect and it comes from cancer and so
there's this other switch that happens
like I'll explain it anyways but in the
Warburg effect it's yeah like oxidative
phosphorylation switches to glycolysis
and this happens in
um cellular reprogramming as well and so
like that's one of the things that I
might be I think might be directly
causally Downstream of
um alterations to the steady state
membrane potential of cells that you
might be trying to reprogram and that
um there might be some key point of
intervention I guess between those two
things but again I'm speaking totally
speculatively and so I would like
preface that with with that being the
case yeah yeah nice sure I can play on
the stunts but those are those those are
the yeah
um and so um the other thing I guess on
from that as well as like in terms of
long-term ideas I guess you would expect
there maybe to be different potential
interventions or different ways to
reprogramming depending on the cell type
or do you think there might just be some
sort of universal uh way of or like some
sort of universal layer of information
that could uh be applied to multiple
cell types
I I see an opportunity for a cell type
um independent like cell type agnostic
intervention and that's goes back to
this idea of like why do I think that
this is interesting rather than kind of
continuing to play at the level of like
the genome looking for a more effective
cellular reprogramming intervention
um and that's another one of the things
that sort of attracts me they're like
other good companies and people doing
work in this space that figure out how
to achieve pretty efficient like
cellular reprogramming for multiple
different reasons like at the level of
an individual like sort of cell type but
um again going back to this idea of like
getting into the weeds of things and
being like but okay how far are we from
like an actual
um uh like aging therapeutic based off
of that research like
I think that this type of work might be
able to be more directly bridged into
achieving something like that with
um yeah cell agnostic like intervention
I as I would say you have this I guess a
huge interest in bioelectricity
um but you've been attending some of
these Asian conferences are there any
other areas besides like I guess your
direct research area that you think is
still promising or that you find
interesting
um the the thing that I find really
interesting is just this idea of like
information like if if like if I think
more generally about the things that I'm
interested in and like the types of
research that like I'm doing
specifically I'm like exploring ideas
through the lens of biology because
that's like the modality that I want to
contribute to but really what I'm
interested in and like is intervention
strategies and complex systems and so in
saying that it's not exactly like a
biology or an even aging space that I
think is really interesting and
important to pay attention to but it's
it's interesting because it's actually
how I came across Michael's work Michael
Levin's work
um is he had hired a neuroscientist
um into his lab like I was kind of
saying earlier that created this
framework that he refers to as causal
emergence and so this is the idea that
redundant information can become more
synergistic and more causally relevant
in regards to the ways that things are
happening at like a lower scale of a
complex system at higher skills over
time and that's sort of like the 10 000
foot view of what's going on there and
so this was like the set of ideas that I
was much more familiar with before I
really started to
um like I had my basic understandings of
biology but I'd been like really curious
by
um this framework and some of the things
that this person who created it Eric
Howell was sort of getting at in regards
to like this work and so that's why
whenever like I saw him kind of go over
to Tufts and start to apply these same
types of ideas and biological systems I
was like whoa okay I gotta I gotta
follow what's going on over here
um and so yeah like that's that's
another space that I think is really
interesting I guess broadly speaking for
anybody listening who's curious I would
say like
it's kind of neuroscientists
Neuroscience it's kind of information
Theory but it's like really study of
Consciousness stuff
which is what's really fascinating but
another sort of uh Fringe domain like
longevity
um in the sense of like it's really
really hard to create like like we don't
even have a box around aging yeah right
like we don't have like a good
conceptual framework like we have things
like methylation clocks and
um these sorts of things but we don't
have like a good
um standard definition to say like you
know like how how do we actually
categorize what it is in such like an
empirical way that we can say for
certain whatever we're doing doing
something that
um is accelerating it or decelerating it
and
um Consciousness is the same type of
problem of like okay we're trying to
like understand this thing this
subjective experience but like we don't
have enough of a box around what the
thing is to like judge the types of work
that we're doing to explore that thing
um really really like effectively yeah
no I completely agree
um and I mean so what seems from my
perspective is clear that you've done a
huge amount of research and
um what independent research to get this
high level of understanding and I guess
one of my questions is how did you
remain focused throughout this or like
what other tips advice uh would you give
for someone who's potentially interested
in doing something very similar like
you've done
um yeah I'm like super happy to give
this like input as someone who is like
listening to you and would have loved to
have heard it at some point in the past
but like it's I think the thing that I
would say that has accelerated the ways
that I think about things that the most
is like remaining like having my core
Focus which is like biology and
Longevity and like the wanting to do
work and research in this space but
remaining really curious and open to new
ideas in different spaces and having
sort of like a generalist mindset
um it's sort of like
it'll sound like a non-sequitur for a
minute but like it's something that
comes to my mind that I remember like
having a big impact on just like
thinking about these types of things is
I was listening to this interview like
literally it'll sound silly but like
right with Kanye West where he says
something to the two like he gets asked
a question like how have you been so
successful in like music and art and
fashion and all these other things right
um and he kind of pauses for a moment
moment and says something to the tune of
like everything in the world is exactly
the same and they're like I don't think
you understood the question and he's
like I don't think you understood the
answer right and so what I mean by that
is like this idea of like borrowing
Concepts from say like Neuroscience or
information Theory or someone else whose
work I think is really exciting that
we've like also had on our podcast the
same Lee Cronin he's doing work sort of
like in chemistry of life and assembly
Theory and these sorts of things I think
that's super super fascinating and like
I can't say that I've like borrowed
ideas from that framework specifically
that have been formed the way that I'm
doing like research in biology but it's
like a hundred percent like inspired
ways that I think about things in terms
of like you know emergent properties
based on like enough time time going on
to like have things like life happen and
so um I think that's sort of like the
the thing that I would say in lieu of
like the sort of like the brute force
method of just like keep doing things
um that make sense independent of like
the constraints of different systems
um like keep a generalist sort of like
mindset
um and if you're going to work outside
of the standard silos anyways like
um let the walls bleed through ideas
from different spaces as well because I
think that that's been really really
useful in regards to how I think about
things
um I'd say is there anything that's
um my audience can see to help you any
sort of ways that people could help you
in the next stage of your progression
um if not is there anywhere I can direct
my viewers to find out more about what
it is you're doing
um for now I would definitely just say
my website
um because that's the place where I kind
of just like publish things open source
um like I said this paper was really a
means of like I did a lot of the work to
basically do a review without actually
structuring it into a review and so
um uh that that was kind of the purpose
of that being done there but to answer
your question
um that's the nature of working as an
independent like I would love to talk to
people that are excited and I guess at
the very least like if it's not help and
there's like someone who's listening
who's like also just listening to The
Cheeky Science Show because they're like
interested in biology or doing work in
the space or aging related things and
like maybe you're just like a software
engineer or you know some other
orthogonal thing and not in the space
yet but like really wanting to be like
definitely just like reach out and it's
not even like about helping me it's just
like um let's have a conversation and if
there's someone who wants to have a
space to do independent research like
I'm marking my words right now because
I'm like looking for the things and
spending the the money I will have a
like lab research space in St Louis
Missouri for like people to come hack on
things so shoot me a note if you need a
space to come hack on things and you're
like me and you don't want to go to the
coasts and you just want a place to work
without constraints why can I need I
wish she the best of lack of all of that
I will for sure put your links in the
description and I'm super excited to see
what you get up to
um and yeah I'm sure we'll be speaking
again sometime soon so yeah just thank
you for coming on today and um again I
can highly encourage my viewers to read
your review of your article because I
think it really is a nice overview about
the current things we do and don't know
in the space and yeah just best of luck
it's been great fun talking to you today
it's been awesome to be here thank you
for having me Eleanor so I hope you've
learned something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening